good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP
1055 object class
CER special containment procedures as CP
1055 is an infohazard information in
this document is presented strictly on a
need to know basis for containment
Personnel accessing additional
information requires level five approval
and accepts the risk of creating a
Containment
Breach SCP 1055's living quarters are
accessible via Subterranean monil from
site 77 two Personnel responsible for
providing care to SCP 1055 are to be
rotated in every 8 hours for 24-Hour
observation SCP 1055's living quarters
contain a playroom with television futon
and sound system a washroom a library
stocked with children's books and a
kitchen staff are encouraged to provide
any Meal which SCP 1055 asks for within
appropriate nutritional guidelines if
current supplies do not meet
requirements substitutions of pasta or
sugary cereals are commonly accepted CP
1055 will fixate upon a random object
currently a teddy bear referred to as
Bugsy and clutch it tightly at all times
staff must allow and encourage this
Behavior even during bathing and feeding
SCP 1055 May vocalize unhappiness or
deliver warnings on behalf of this
object any requests concerning this
object must be met by all possible means
available containment of SCP 1055
depends primarily on both its isolation
and positive social attitude in the
event of catastrophe staff are to
evacuate and flood the living quarters
with nitrous oxide under no
circumstances is any physical harm to be
done to SCP 1055 even and especially if
it becomes
hostile additional information delete or
destroy after reading as per HP 5810
regarding Forbidden Knowledge
disposal containment of SCP 1055 depends
primarily upon the health and well-being
of its caretaker
d155 due to SCP 1055's extreme reactions
to human perception successful
containment requires that staff on site
be misdirected to believe that
d155 is the anomalous entity himself
d155 is of diminished mental faculty but
aware of the importance of his service
in keeping pugy Safe in His Arms d 1055
has thus far presented the only viable
means of containing SCP 1055 without
massive loss of personnel and
resources level four Personnel Who
oversee containment of SCP 1055 are not
allowed within 50 km of site 77 nor may
they directly interact with any
Personnel tasked with its
maintenance description SCP 1055 is
formerly Michael Schroeder of Douglas
Wyoming he is a Caucasian male 6'4 in
tall and 280 lb 29 years of age and
suffers from autistic spectrum disorder
and down syndrome SCP 1055 may be
addressed as 1055 Mikey or any nickname
which He suggests despite classification
as an anomaly staff are encouraged to
address SCP 1055 with normal social
pronouns in documentation and
conversation
additional information delete or destroy
after reading as per HP 5810 regarding
Forbidden Knowledge
disposal under normal conditions SCP
1055 superficially resembles a specimen
of uous arctos horribilis however its
volume mass and morphology shift
spontaneously the means by which SCP
1055 gains and loses mass is not
understood but it appears to be in
relation to the number and proximity of
individuals who are aware of SCP 1055
and the nature of the attention it
receives from them hostile or fearful
awareness of SCP 1055 increases its size
and hostility significantly more than
benign awareness but due to SCP 1055's
violent nature even a calm awareness of
its existence can quickly spiral into a
potential Containment Breach as the
danger it presents escalates and exposes
itself to more
individuals in the event of a
catastrophic exposure to human awareness
SCP 1055 will quickly be overwhelmed by
its own size and will no longer be able
to effectively move it will however it
will continue to grow and produce
sensory organs and appendages which are
used to assault any living creature
Within Reach even in confined or
Subterranean locations SCP 1055's growth
can exert enough pressure to cause
tremors and massive structure failure
and pieces of the biomass are capable of
growing through and widening gaps or
cracks of any size apart from its mass
generation SCP 1055 possesses no special
ability to resist trauma portions of SCP
1055's biomass that are removed via
trauma do not regenerate or continue
living
independently however about 75% of any
hostile action taken against SCP 1055 to
date has failed to destroy more of the
organism than the very act itself
generated even in circumstances where
the trauma was applied remotely via
bombing or automated defenses no upper
limit to the size or lethality of SCP
1055's biomass has been established
during containment breaches and exposure
to civilians and unscreened Personnel
the only event which has ever been shown
to effectively reduce SCP 1055 in size
is the death of at least 80% of the IND
individuals aware of its existence
amnestics of any class are not
sufficient to eliminate awareness total
elimination of SCP 1055 is hypothesized
to require the extermination of all
previously exposed
individuals including the 05 Council
itself and anyone who is reading this
document
it it is the A5 council's unanimous
opinion that a failure to properly
restrain SCP 1055 could quickly spiral
into an XK class scenario if its
existence became publicly
known addendum containment procedures
adapted from captured group of Interest
intelligence the group of Interest was
unsuccessfully researching attempts to
destroy SCP 2055 which led to its escape
and
subsequent access additional information
delete or destroy after reading as per h
5810 regarding Forbidden Knowledge
disposal current procedure was adopted
following SCP 1055's 12th Containment
Breach which resulted in sustained
Precision bombing upon former site 76
and the loss of all Personnel within
with the exception of d155 previously
classified d49 2291 C form 10 5546
regarding termination exemption double
blind recovery teams found d155 alone in
the rubble clinging to the shredded
remains of SCP
1055 as a security blanket it is
hypothesized that d155 lacks the full
capability to understand Bugsy's true
nature and that as his awareness of SCP
1055 is obsessively protective and
affectionate he is not capable of
triggering the escalating growth and
hostility that normal human interaction
with SCP 1055
produces according to interviews with
containment Personnel it appears that
SCP 1055 itself either currently lacks
the body and muscle mass to resist
d155 or it simply lacks the will to
resist the majority of personnel have
been successfully convinced that SCP
1055 is a poorly sewn if disturbingly
realistic stuffed
animal any movement or rather
indications to the contrary have been
attributed to d10 55s supposed anomalous
nature I don't care that this
Arrangement has worked out the best out
of all the previously scrapped
containment schemes it is not
sustainable in the long run to ask a
mentally challenged man to keep the end
of the world at Bay with hugs we need a
long-term solution preferably orbital or
Oceanic to keep exposure to human
awareness at an absolute minimum oh
510 tell Mikey that we're taking Bugsy
away and we're facing a brand new
Containment Breach I recommend doing so
in person that would be at least one
less person who knows about this thing
055 via protocol 12 we are already
recruiting in plenty of mentally
challenged individuals for ker work we
are grooming future candidates to
inherit d155 duties and to act as a
backup if the worst happen happens argue
all you want for putting it in the sky
where anyone can see it this is the
cheaper and safer option by far
057 this concludes today's lecture thank
you for listening if indeed you still
are and you were all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaran jack wall o crop guy James
Saba Lost Boy
segnar your local Foundation agent
zazaon worthy fire cubster Dean
dingis Mr
duuk oscuro vision
Grim near extra moments 1
23 and Swift
raw if you would like a special thank
you at the end of each of my videos and
some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com Thee vulgan thank
you